your tax Affairs a distraction for the
party Mr Sahari not just a distraction
this destructive too allegations around
your tax Affairs going to torpedo your
bidstar now Nadeem zahawi's tax Affairs
torpedo in not just his leadership bid
but his cabinet job too have you been
honest about your tax Affairs Mr zahawi
sacked from government for failing to
come clean about a dispute over his tax
bill
a short investigation by the PM's ethics
advisor sir Laurie Magnus concluded that
Mr zahawi's conduct as a minister has
fallen below the high standards that as
prime minister you rightly expect from
those who serve in your government
the PM's response was Swift right into
his former party chair to say it is
clear that there's been a serious breach
of the ministerial code as a result I
have informed you of my decision to
remove you from your position we do once
all the facts are laid out need decisive
action and that is what the Prime
Minister has given today decisive action
but only after a full and proper
investigation due process then effective
decision making
but this was an investigation that
revealed that while Mr zahari was
appointed to various cabinet positions
under three different Prime Ministers he
was simultaneously being investigated by
tax authorities which he didn't declare
the tax investigation was underway in
April 2021 when Nadeem Sahari fast dealt
with hmrc he claims at this point he
didn't realize this was a formal inquiry
issuing this denial to Sky News last
summer so I was clearly being smeared I
was being told that that the serious
thought offers that the national
crimeacy that hmrc are looking uh into
me I'm not aware of this I will I've
always declared my taxes I paid my taxes
in the UK three months later lawyers for
Mr zahari threatened legal action when
further reports of an investigation
surfaced the unpaid tax and a penalty
were eventually settled while he was
Chancellor but Mr zahari failed to
declare this or correct the record until
earlier this month
just 11 days ago Mr sunac was back in
his chairman my honorable friend has
already addressed this matter in full
and that's nothing more that I can add
while labor accused the government of
being slow to act why did Rishi sinaksi
in Parliament that all questions had
been answered about this affair and why
on Earth is the prime minister holding
up this Rogues gallery of conservative
ministers in Mr zahari's constituency
today a sense that this is a problem far
bigger than just one MP there is an
interculture of irresponsibility no
accountability they are simply there to
serve their own purpose do you think the
Prime Minister Rishi should have acted
more swiftly to sack him or yes really
but for the conservatives because
they've lost the block now anyway
if Nadeem zahawi's tax row looked bad
before today the formal investigation
has made things even worse the former
party chair has been found to have
broken the ministerial code not once but
numerous times and failed to be open and
honest in his dealings as for his boss
Rishi sunak is trying to show the public
he's clamping down on sleaze but this
Scandal has undoubtedly left a stain not
just on Mr zahawi but on the
conservative party the government and
the Prime Minister too
the Prime Minister will on Monday try to
turn the page but these first hundred
days have been more about sleaze than
sound government and it leaves the PM
with even more ground to make up Beth
Rigby Sky News in Westminster